the Backstreet Boys are officially
headed to Las Vegas for a new residency
in 2017 and they've already got one
ticket sold two in sinks Lance Bass how
do you Altima do you have FOMO do you
want anything to do that oh my god the
ultimate dream of an artist is to get a
residency in Vegas um you know I think
Elvis and all the manna they started
that years ago and then it just came
back in the 2000s where and I think
Britney and Celine and everyone just
made it the most amazing thing ah yes
I'm very jealous I would love to be able
to have a residency in Vegas with the
NSYNC boys you get to stay in the same
hotel every single night that that right
there is just worth it today get to be
settled yes yes it'd be amazing I'm
excited for the show I will be there
opening night for sure I like it
sadly no new music is in the works from
Lance or in sync he's focused on TV
right now currently hosting logos
finding prince charming and developing a
music series with some up powerhouse
pals Kris Jenner and I uh and Robin
Antin created the show I know let's get
dolls yeah she created the Pussycat
Dolls and GRL genome she's done amazing
with girl bands and I've you know had a
little work with the boy bands just a
little success yeah so uh so we are
gonna go out there and develop and
create the next great American boy band
and girl bands and of course America
gets to vote which ones you know they
want the best and then Kris Jenner is
gonna be the manager oh yeah ooh so with
that I get to get back in the studio I
get to write and produce a lot of this
music for other bands so I'm excited to
start doing that
you